a number of fresh fires breaking out in
two different provinces they're talking
about at least 10
large fires in five provinces and this
is a new one that's been
raging overnight i mean it's very very
thick with smoke
and cloudy because of that and naturally
there's a very gentle
flutter of ash rain all the time
because there's that hill which now you
cannot see
is absolutely covered in flames and it's
raging
across let me have a little look so you
see where we are we've got the coastline
over here
where um tourists and holiday makers
tourists and holiday makers uh were here
just
just uh well a few hours ago they were
swimming in the sea
and what they're trying to do
apologies for the loud speaker he's
urgently trying to get a number of uh
residents have parked their cars along
this road to see the fire
and he's trying to get them to move so
they can get more fire trucks in here
up on that hill they are trying to stop
the spread of the flames
because it's heading towards this area
and a very large
coal power station which serves
over 500 000 people in the area and they
want to stop the fire
getting into that area it's only a few
kilometers away and bringing down the
power for the
pretty much the whole region um they
still suffering from an urgent and
critical lack of
of air support uh the mayor of mila's
this region has put out an appeal for
more air support saying that he needs it
desperately in the next few
hours next 24 hours or so will be
crucial at the moment they're relying on
helicopters and other air support from
countries like russia you can see one
just coming in now and
forcing kevin to point right into the
sun but
i don't know whether you can make out
through the cloud and smoke haze
this helicopter look at the conditions
that they're having to work in
it's incredibly hot but it's still
fairly early in the morning
and in the the seat of the fire when
you're going into that smoke the
temperatures
firefighters and the aircraft crews are
talking about it going up to
50 degrees so the situation is still
very much at a crucial stage with
forecasts
for much higher temperatures continuing
high temperatures for the next week or
so